[Music]  this is Aspen a tutored slot slots spend  almost their entire lives hanging in  trees and do nearly everything upside  down eating sleeping mating even giving  birth since it spends so much time  upside down assless fur grows in the  opposite direction of all other mammals  this allows water to run off the sloth  when it rains its fur also has minut  grooves their collecting grow algae  giving wild sloths a greenish tint and  providing excellent camouflage a sloths  powerful claws are perfectly adapted for  gripping and climbing trees but become a  nuisance when on the ground surprisingly  though they are excellent swimmers and  have been known to drop into the water  and swim to a new tree despite these  adaptations sloths face many threats  their forest homes are increasingly  becoming fragmented making breeding  difficult and they are a popular target  for traffickers in the illegal pet trade  this is the two toed sloth  you  [Music]